la carte bleue n'a jamais aussi bien
porté son nom ce mois de juin lunettes
de soleil t-shirt claquettes les
produits dérivés aux couleurs de
l'équipe de france s'arrache dans les
boutiques yvelinoise le best seller le
maillot officiel
aujourd'hui on n'a même pas besoin de
faire de publicité quoi que ce soit mais
qui en quand il arrive la première chose
qu'une demande avait déjà eu une équipe
de france
oui il est là il est pour vous donc
demandé de donner connais moins 10 votre
taille et puis je me ferais un plaisir
d'aller vouloir récupérer au total 6000
euros de produits qui de france ont été
vendus en une semaine dans ce magasin et
le parcours des bleus en aussi pour
encore booster les ventes jusqu'à
épuiser les stocks
la relecture de ce peuple qu'on n'est
jamais à l'abri de cela bien sûr après
je pense que dès que dès que la coupe du
monde va se lancer
on est aussi cadets par rapport aux
résultats de la france parce que si
jamais la france commence eu des matches
de préparation avec des scores fleuves
ou même des victoires
forcément ça va se sentir sur les ventes
un engouement qui devrait se propager
dans les bars dans ce pub installé
depuis 1998 à voisins le bretonneux
les supporters étaient déjà présents ce
samedi 9 juin pour suivre le dernier
match amical contre les états unis
le taux de remplissage devrait encore
augmenter pour les premiers matches
officiels de la coupe du monde c'est
ceinture une soirée où il ya l'équipe de
france qui joue
moi j'ai comme j'ai dit c'est à midi on
sait pas trop mais quand c'est à 20h30
c'est
100 % de remplissage donc
l'établissement est au complet et il
faut réserver pour avoir de la place
quoi pour boire un verre c'est debout et
pour manger ouais faut réserver à
l'avancé puis les places assises mal
cher on va dire au delà du cadre
commercial sur les terrains la coupe du
monde est aussi un moyen d'attirer de
nouveaux licenciés dans les yvelines on
a observé une hausse de 18 % de joueurs
après le dernier mondial au brésil
un phénomène que le président d'honneur
de l'étoile sportive de tram mustapha
larbaoui connaît bien depuis son arrivée
au club en 2003 il ya une telle
concentration de match une telle
concentration d'image une telle
concentration de stars finalement c'est
eux c'est notre festival de cannes tous
les quatre ans et puis les faits encore
une fois nation donc la france en
particulier
forcément pas forcément oui il ya il ya
cet engagement particulier
aujourd'hui le département compte 39
1817 licencié ce chiffre pourrait
exploser si la france remporte une
deuxième étoile le 15 juillet prochain
en russie